[Music]
oMG you guys the 90210 reboots is less
than three months away and I'm not sure
who's more excited me or the og cast
something new we've been working on for
a couple of years now and it's been the
20 years of making I don't know the
labor of love
a labor of love here's everything we
know so far first of all it's only six
episodes it's about the making of a
reboot where the cast basically plays
heightened versions of themselves
kind of like when james van der beek to
bat on don't trust the B in apartment 23
Oh James everyone's done a reboot kind
of 90210 had a newer version that was
different but I didn't want it to be
another reboot Edie was with the cast
earlier this month
and here's what they spilled number one
it's scripted it's all entirely scripted
but it but it's a lot more of a comedy
it's the cast its us making a reboot
number do where it picks up and we're
gonna all gonna pick up with the stories
the way they were when you ended the
series audience so we're doing like a
meta version of reboot and they'll be
the new show 3 we might see their kids
this is gonna be a different show yeah
and we're originally it was the kids
have brought the parents to the show
right when we come back now it's going
to be the parents of the kids right but
don't expect any David silver break
dancing
no don't break something I don't think I
have now we know the reboot has been
plagued with a little drama stop switch
ups and Feud rumors we doing it but et
has learned that filming is underway and
quote everything is moving along well
and even shannen doherty took to
Instagram to dispel stories she's the
root of any issues quote I refuse to be
cast in the same villain role please
stop trying to tell your wildly and
accurate exaggerated a story of me well
the past is the past and the future is
the future so good to be back together
again it just feels like you're back
with your family we're excited
[Music]
as for how the cast is going to deal
with the passing of Luke Perry
he wasn't signed on to be part of the
reboot though we've learned he was
likely going to make a cameo agape your
sister man she made it and a source
tells ET quote they all want to ensure
Luke's memory lives on through the show
do you have a fond memory of Luke
the reboot premieres on Fox on August
7th and for all the latest on all things
men are - and oh and make sure you keep
it locked to all things et until next
time I'm Katie crafts and bye for now